you want a pina colada
that's a lot of sugar
okay
hey guys pete here today i'm going to
look at the ending of the first season
of the hbo series the white lotus in
case you didn't hear it's been renewed
for a second season and it's gonna shift
from a limited series to an anthology
series i'm gonna recap everything that
happened in the finale and then i'm
gonna get into the ending and there will
be chapter markers at the bottom if you
just want to skip ahead to that just a
quick warning for spoilers if you
haven't finished all of season 1's six
episodes then this video isn't for you
and with that out of the way let's get
into it
vacation is almost over and the final
episode of the first season of the white
lotus opens with everyone waking up for
their final day on the island rachel
looks really uncomfortable in bed with
shane quinn wakes up on the beach and
jumps in the canoe paula's frantically
trying to text kai to see if he's okay
mark and nicole are having sex they're
saying things like this is why people go
on vacation they're super happy she
calls him superman in a scuba suit and
so the robbery brought them closer
together and we see he gets to feel like
a man which was something that he was
after earlier in the season tanya wakes
up she finds out greg really enjoyed
last night he's okay with her crazy side
and that goes a long way to making her
feel better considering her insecurities
quinn returns to the room he's all
pumped up from the canoe trip and he
tells his parents he wants to stay in
hawaii they point out the obvious that
he's still a miner and he's still in
school and really nobody gets to do
things like that back at the patton's
room shane's on the phone with a travel
agent complaining when rachel asks why
he tells her about the mossbacher
robbery and he gets himself all worked
up about not having a gun not having a
bat or something and then he settles on
grabbing the knife the hotel gave them
to cut pineapples he puts it on the
nightstand next to his bed and it makes
you wonder if that's going to be
important later on while she was getting
her facial rachel did work up the nerve
and she tells him she thinks their
marriage was a mistake he turns things
around saying oh wow you hid yourself
really well here i was thinking you were
this cool chick and really you're just a
baby she fires back with actual examples
of him being a baby on their trip how
he's cuddled by his mother how she
showed up for their honeymoon and the
never-ending tantrum that he's been
throwing over the room this exchange
does show the faulty foundation of their
relationship he can't hear her i really
even understand where she's coming from
for him everything's good therefore the
only options are her going along with
that or messing it up when she says that
she doesn't want to spend her life as a
plus one his answer is just don't be
that and he can't understand why that's
a problem the mossbachers are heading
out for their scuba dive armin stops
them to let them know that the thief was
caught and that they'll be getting their
jewelry back they ask if it was an
employee and when he says yes olivia
makes a point of asking for the name and
they do find out it was kai
armond throws it out there that he can't
believe it that he was such a nice guy
he was such a good employee he never
caused any problems and he would have
never guessed and so paula realizes that
she corrupted him
mark and quinn have their dive and it
looks amazing they even swim with the
sea tortoise and there's several points
in this finale where they emphasized the
natural beauty of the island i suppose
they did that throughout the series but
it really stands out here and it feels a
little different knowing that the one
indigenous person we met is probably on
their way to prison and while the guys
are in the water we see paula take the
necklace she got from kai and throw it
overboard at the desk garmin gets a call
from the owner he knows he's going to
get fired now he heads to his office he
tells dylan to come with him inside he
starts crushing up pills says they're
gonna go hard and he's basically off to
the races
when dylan asks him if it's a kamikaze
situation if maybe he's gonna be taken
down too armand just says hey they
exploit me i exploit you that's how it
works and if you're gonna lose your job
you might as well do it now before you
waste your entire life
when they return to the room olivia
confronts paula telling her that she
knows she was involved with the robbery
paula eventually comes clean and just
says you know you don't understand it
was never about me the conversation ends
with olivia saying you know something
bad could have happened my mom could
have been hurt apologist says the truth
something bad did happen over at the spa
tanya comes in to tell belinda goodbye
she thanks her for the help thanks her
for being so great but essentially says
she doesn't want to do the business
anymore she turns it around saying that
it's an unhealthy situation for her
because it's like falling into this old
pattern she latches on to someone and
then she tries to control them with her
money the truth is she really is just
focused on greg now things are going
good there he seems to accept her so
that gives her some room to have this
insight and it comes down to her doing
something that makes her feel good
something that works for her rather than
focusing on something that could help
someone else
armond is all tuned up and he goes to
host his last dinner you see him in all
his glory working the crowd seating
everyone you can really see how good
he's gotten at his job over the years of
course he does look a little tweaked out
and shane notices that when he mentions
it that opens the door for him and
rachel to have a conversation about
what's going on he tells his wife that
whenever she gets over whatever's going
on with her he'll be there he's her
husband and he cares and then he
proceeds to get angry when she doesn't
magically get better as a result of him
saying that and he even bangs on the
table asking her why are you trying to
ruin everything at one point she tells
him that she feels weirdly alone when
they're together and when he doesn't
really have anything to say to that he
just says fine then be alone and he goes
to the bar and starts throwing back
double tequilas greg has another
coughing fit at the bar and he can see
that tanya is concerned so he tells her
that he has some health issues he says
don't be surprised if i drop dead and
tonya drops one of her best replies in a
series where she's had quite a few of
them saying that death is the one fully
immersive experience she hasn't tried
yet and with that everything's in place
for the ending
the end plays out like this armand is
pumped saying he did an amazing job at
dinner he continues to get high with
dylan and a couple of the other staff
members that have now joined him and
eventually he gets up to walk to the
pineapple suite and gets a great idea to
take a dump in shane's suitcase
belinda throws her business plan in the
trash knowing that fat envelope of cash
is the only thing she's ever going to
see from tonya she had given her number
to rachel earlier when she saw her
crying and she does call belinda helps
her get her own room and then listens to
her talk about her problems but when
rachel asks her for advice she says
she's all out she doesn't have anything
left in the mossbacher room paula's in
bed crying and olivia gets closer to hug
her make her feel better she says she
[ __ ] everything up and olivia says
it's okay
shane comes back to his room armond's
still in there he tries to hide in the
closet but shane smells something and he
discovers the present that armon left
him in his suitcase he calls the front
desk to complain armond tries to sneak
out shane hears a noise and he grabs the
knife and then eventually stabs him when
he comes around the corner and it does
turn out to be fatal after it all plays
out you see shane talking to the police
with the hotel staff by his side he
doesn't look terribly torn up and it's
wild because they seem to buy his story
of self-defense without really delaying
him in any way like he stabbed someone
to death in his room one day and he's
leaving the jurisdiction the next
quinn wakes up on the beach for his last
morning you can see a tear roll down his
cheek as he takes in all the beauty
tanya walks into the frame and she goes
to the water to scatter her mother's
ashes she's finally ready to put it all
behind her and looks almost as blissful
as she did when she was imagining the
moment earlier in the season at the
airport armond's remains are being
loaded onto the flight to honolulu
shane's watching through the window and
it brings us full circle to the teaser
flash forward from the first episode
only this time we get to see what
happens after rachel does arrive at the
ticket counter after spending her night
alone and he walks directly over and she
looks at him and says everything's fine
i'm happy i promise i will be happy and
they hug and she just sort of stares
into the distance and he just sort of
looks relieved that she's finally come
to her senses
at the gate we get a final look at all
the guests greg and tanya look happy
nicole and mark are beaming you can see
that she's got her 75 000 bracelets back
paula and olivia are reading it's time
to go back to the real world they start
boarding with quinn lagging behind his
family he stops waits till they make it
through the gate and then he makes a
break for it back at the resort you see
the staff they're smiling and waving to
welcome the next boat full of vips and
in the closing shot you see quinn in the
canoe paddling towards the idyllic
sunrise
if you're keeping score how did
everybody do well the rich people they
all got what they wanted more or less
and the people trying to make a living
serving them not so much and you might
think to yourself well that sucks but as
a piece of social satire it's pretty
consistent with where things were going
and with reality
you may not like it but don't be like
the mossbachers and try to cling onto
the idea that it's not how things really
are money rules everything money makes
money the rich get richer and you could
go on but i think it really would have
dulled the edge of what the show was
trying to say if it didn't end this way
[ __ ] rolls downhill and the consequences
for making mistakes is different
depending on where you rank in the
pecking order there's a real possibility
that the characters in this show and the
people in society that they're a
reflection of would prefer to be
miserable rather than give up anything
that they have and feel like they
deserve you could say what you want
about the system that makes all this
possible its sustainability the damage
that it continues to cause across the
globe just to keep itself going but i
think what the show was really good at
getting across is the feeling that these
people have about their situation as
opposed to what their situation really
is
mark lays it out perfectly when he says
nobody seeds their privilege that's
absurd it goes against human nature
we're all just trying to win the game of
life i think that's what you can take
away from the ending these aren't the
worst people in the world they aren't
the most diabolical characters ever
conceived for a television series and
you can probably even find some moments
of relatability in some of their
perspectives they've bought into the
system and even when they can't see it
and maybe it doesn't even happen
consciously but they're trying to hold
on to that and preserve it if you look
at the individual endings the robbery
fixed things up for nicole and mark the
situation with armond and the ripple
effects of belinda not having anything
left when rachel really did need advice
that all brought shane and rachel back
together at first i wasn't sure about
the quinn leaving the airport and
paddling off into the sunrise that whole
thing but i suppose it's grown on me for
one he was the only guest who was
actually getting something from being on
the island and things could have felt
really bleak if there wasn't at least an
uplifting moment there what's funny is
that when you first watch it you're
thinking oh well maybe he gets a happy
ending but if they showed us anything
through mark and nicole and how he slept
on the beach and how olivia's so cynical
towards them it's that they don't really
pay much attention to their kids so it's
actually possible that they just didn't
notice he wasn't on the plane when they
went to honolulu and then when they got
there they went after him there's really
no guarantee that he's gonna get to stay
there thanks to her treatments with
belinda tonya makes what she thinks is a
healthy decision to avoid falling into a
pattern and she does that by falling
into a more immediately instantly
gratifying pattern and the idea that
rachel finds herself in this position so
fast after marrying into money it
actually means that she's got something
to lose and that changes things in a
really uncomfortable way status is a
hell of a drug olivia and paula had the
one relationship and were the characters
that you could kind of still hope that
they would evolve given their age i mean
it's easy to be critical of your family
and their place in things when they're
still supporting you through college
olivia doesn't seem like someone who's
taking on debt to be at school but what
comes next you know what about when she
integrates into that same system paula
made a mistake and someone else paid the
price there's no undoing that she did it
thinking it wasn't about her but it
wasn't really ever about kai either it
was to hurt the mossbachers and she felt
justified because of olivia stealing her
previous boyfriend and you have to hope
that she'll be able to see that and
become a better person and of course
that goes for all of them but with the
younger people it just feels like it
might be more possible armond and kai's
endings are obviously tragic and they
hit different things in different ways
neither one of them was perfect in the
first episode armond didn't even realize
that the woman he was training was
pregnant and even though he was coaxed
into it by paula i did make a decision
to go into that room and try to steal
the bracelets you could say that armand
should have just backed down but he's a
character who's worked in this business
for a long time he knows that once shane
owns him there'll be no end to what he
has to deal with over the next week so
you kind of understand why he decided to
fight back i think the point is though
that there are consequences for their
mistakes whereas you look at a guy like
shane and you could make a debate kind
of argument about how he was right all
along but all of it really would be
missing the point what he did was
self-defense someone came into his room
and from his perspective that was a
threatening situation but look how
easily he walked away from it a guy like
kai he's gonna spend time in prison the
crime he committed breaking and entering
the value of what he stole his life is
never gonna be the same so i thought it
was a fun six episodes and a really nice
commentary on these characters there
were a lot of smart moments in the way
they were presented and i thought it was
one of the better uses of the flash
forward sort of in medius rest openings
that have become really popular because
streaming shows really want to get you
hooked in right at the beginning you get
the idea that it's more of a character
study slash social satire than a mystery
but you also know someone's gonna end up
dead and that makes a lot of little
things take on weight quinn and mark's
diving and his canoe trips greg's
coughing armon's declaration that he's
gonna go hard with the drugs and of
course shane's grabbing the knife i
think they pulled that off really well i
also quite liked how they kept the focus
away from the tragedy at the end kai's
ordeal all happens off screen there's no
direct mention of arm and after he dies
life at the resort goes on as if they
never existed the guests lives go on
after a great vacation with just a few
minor inconveniences the performances
were all superb the natural backdrop was
great to look at if you can just sort of
not focus on the imperialism of it all
and the score was absolutely amazing i
can't really overstate how many times i
found myself locked into whatever was
happening on screen
and realized that i was nearly
hypnotized by the music and i suppose
that's as good a place as any to leave
things i could go on but let's do that
in the comments instead
let me know what you thought about the
show the satire the characters the
themes and what you thought about the
finale another season doesn't sound like
a bad idea in a different place with a
different cast i guess they will need to
come up with a way to make each season
feel fresh and unique but it looks like
they've got a good handle on things
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon